after struggling to get financing
exhaustive reshoots and having the set
rated by a SWAT team it's a miracle that
World War Z got finished at all the
Journey of World War Z as a film began
years before it hit the big screen but
Mark Forrester joining the project as
its director in 2008 while J Michael
strasinski was the first person hired to
pen the screenplay for the film
adaptation of the max Brooks book of the
same name Forster's participation here
was intriguing in terms of timing since
it came a few months before his feature
Quantum of Solace debut and established
that he could direct Blockbuster level
movies in talking about his vision for
the film Forester used conspiracy
Thrillers of the 1970s namely All the
President's Men as touchstones for what
he wanted the vibe of World War Z to be
it was also the fact that the film was
initially set up at Plan B Productions a
production company founded in part by
Brad Pitt after a bidding war with
Leonardo DiCaprio's opian way his outfit
had signed a first look deal with
Paramount pitchers three years earlier
in 2005. a deal that had yielded Awards
season Darlings like The Curious Case of
Benjamin Button and Babel none of these
initial collaborations though had the
kind of widespread appeal of a zombie
action movie like World War Z the
importance of this film to plan B and
Paramount Pictures relationship meant
that even his Forester aimed to make the
new all the president men Paramount
brass likely would have settled for the
director just rehashing other past box
office juggernauts when the screenwriter
J Michael strasinski first talked to MTV
in 2008 to ban his draft for World War Z
an element he kept on emphasizing was
the sheer scope of the movie Bruce
drazinski it was exciting to make a
zombie movie that had such a massive
scale considering how many iconic zombie
films were much more restrained he also
presented an intriguing meta element
related to the original Max Brooks novel
struzinski originally planned to have
the book written in Universe during the
movie so audiences would see the film's
lead writing down events as the story
progressed before ending World War Z
with the text fully written it was a
clever idea in that it figured out how
to adapt a book that seemed difficult to
translate to the big screen strozinski
expressed further excitement over
collaborating with director Mark
Forrester on what he described as a last
draft of the script before the movie got
up and running sometime in 2009.
unfortunately many of these ideas would
not make it into the Final Cut
strzezinski's approach to adapting this
text was so removed from the Final Cut
of World War Z that he only received a
story by credits on the finished film
even before reshoots shot up its budget
significantly World War Z was always
intended to be costlier than your
average zombie movie namely because of
the scope and scale of the script Walt
Disney is definitely the biggest movie
I've ever done the scale is enormous
it's a worldwide Global Journey World
War Z was going to Star Brad Pitt for
one thing while its expansive global
scale ensured that it was always going
to cost a pretty penny to realize even
with all of these elements baked into
the movie from the get-go World War Z at
one point looked too expensive for
Paramount pitchers to finance and
release a few months before principal
photography was supposed to start in
2011 reports emerged that Paramount
Pictures needed to find a co-financier
for World War Z the stakes here was so
significant that the project could be
scrapped if another production company
didn't join in to finance its 150
million dollar budget however a savior
for the zombie Blockbuster came about in
the form of skydance Productions which
had a co-financing deal with Paramount
pitchers at the time the studio stepped
in to help cover the budget of World War
Z thus ensuring that it could go forward
into production Brad Pitt may have saved
what was left of the world in the film
but skydance saved World War Z itself
The Saga of Matthew Fox's participation
in World War Z could be a movie unto
itself in June 2011 just before shooting
began it was first reported that box was
set to be a part of the film's cast
however just a few weeks later it was
revealed that box would not be taking
part in the zombie Blockbuster after all
because of scheduling conflicts with
Alex Cross that's a very normal turn of
events as many actors are reported to be
in talks for a motion picture but don't
end up getting cast what makes this
peculiar is that in August 2011 The
Hollywood Reporter confirmed that fox
was in the movie after all with the
actor simply juggling cross and World
War Z simultaneously talking to Extra TV
in February 2013 Fox expressed
excitement over how World War Z was
shaping up by saying it's a it's going
to be a re-sort of imagining you know
reimagining of the of the zombie genre
it's a big zombie movie but it's going
to be like nothing you've seen before
though he was playing an effective hype
man Fox's role in the Final Cut of World
War Z ended up being so minimal that he
only appears in a few seconds of the
Final Cut as a pilot movies.com reported
that the original ending to World War Z
before its extensive reshoots heavily
involved box character who would have
started a relationship with a
protagonist's wife that plot thread in
nearly all of Fox's role were deleted
from World War Z leaving him barely
visible in the Final Cut as a cast for
World War Z began to assemble the
production began pursuing an award
season darling for a key supporting role
in June 2011 Ed Harris was reported to
be in talks to take on a role in the
future there's no word on who he would
be playing though given his track record
as a performer it's likely Harris would
have been a fine fit for whatever role
World War Z through with the actor up to
this point in his career Harris had
primarily done more grounded projects
with minimal CGI so World War Z could
have been an interesting departure from
his Norms could have though was the
operative Ward there as Harris ended up
passing on World War Z there was never
any indication of what led to Harris
saying no to such a high-profile project
but any hopes of seeing Pitt and Harris
interacting on the big screen were
dashed however Harris may have dodged a
bullet by not signing on to do the film
given that Matthew Fox was largely cut
from the feature there's a good chance
Ed Harris may have also been largely
left on The Cutting floor
in the summer of 2011 the world was
gearing up for the final two seasons of
Breaking Bad the acclaimed program was
nearing the end of the road and that
didn't just mean the inevitable closure
of Walter White's Journey for super fans
of the show it also meant that the main
actors of Breaking Bad were starting to
keep their eyes peeled for new acting
opportunities beyond the acclaimed crime
drama the hit series leading man Brian
Cranston also secured an especially
interesting gig in the Twilight years of
the show by entering into talks for a
very small role in World War Z so what
happens next
I guess we shake on it
and I leave there's no word on who
Cranston would have been playing in the
movie but the part was said to be a
juicy one
you're goddamn right well it seemed like
exciting casting it never came to pass
Cranston informed Film School rejects in
September 2011 that he wasn't going to
be in World War Z after all the actor
explained that he was really eager to do
the movie and work with director Mark
Forrester but scheduling conflicts made
it all but impossible for him to be a
part of the movie no don't don't say
that don't you say that since then
there's been no further information on
who Cranston would have played in this
Blockbuster but perhaps it's best to
leave this perspective casting to pass a
draw Cranston missing out on World War Z
gave him so much more time to fixate on
the final episodes of Breaking Bad
the biggest problem during the
production of World War Z came with its
initial Envy in an openly vulnerable
piece for Vanity Fair the crew behind
the film opened up about how the
original action-packed finale to this
film simply didn't work that initial
climax would see Brad Pitt's protagonist
travel to Russia where he would end up
fighting off swarms of zombies there was
lots of expansive Carnage in the set
piece but the people behind the movie
felt like the character details of World
War Z were getting lost in all the
Mayhem there was also another reason for
changing World War Z so drastically as
Pitt explained to Entertainment Weekly
one reason he signed on for the movie in
the first place was that he wanted to
explore weighty's sociopolitical ideas
within the confines of a zombie action
movie the idea of merging exciting
zombie fighting with Hefty themes
sounded great to Pitt but once World War
Z entered post-production it was decided
that the film was just too heavy
reshoots heavily censored on the third
act were then enacted to ensure that
World War Z was more fun than
thought-provoking the various reasons
behind overhauling the film's climax led
the Paramount pitchers spending Millions
reshaping the Brad Pitt star vehicle in
June 2012 the news broke World War Z was
in trouble though it had started life
with a lot of hype surrounding the idea
of Brad Pitt anchoring a big budget
zombie Blockbuster the feature was now
as tormented as any shambling corpse the
first piece of news of this development
involved Damon Lindelof getting hired to
revamp the movie's third act Lindelof
came up with the idea of how to
streamline the finale and The Cabin in
the Woods director Drew Goddard was then
hired to write down a new resolution
based on lindelof's Concepts Lindelof
later explained to The Hollywood
Reporter that he was hired to work on
World War Z because Brad Pitt had nearly
starred in Prometheus another
Blockbuster penned by Lindelof with a
dynamic established between the two men
Lindelof was called in to listen to Pitt
explain the flaws in the then current
version of World War Z little off
expressed sympathy for how the movie had
ended up going too big in its original
third act traditional zombie pair has
often been intimate in scope so Lindelof
could see the logic of a massive climax
be necessary to differentiate World War
Z from typical zombie fare of course
that tactic ended up backfiring terribly
and it required folks like Lindelof and
Goddard to write up a radically new
ending for the troubled World War Z in
addition to the rewrites the director
Mark Forrester felt that his shift to
suspense rather than sheer spectacle
would prove more satisfying to the
audience you can't get any bigger and
make it even a bigger spectacle so now
you bring it all back to the suspenseful
moment between the Z and your hero even
before those Infamous extensive reshoots
the production of World War Z was
plagued by constant problems case in
point in October 2011 during filming a
warehouse holding weapons for the film
was raided by a SWAT team the weapons
were largely assault rifles with the
issue here being that these were
actually functional objects rather than
the non-functional entities that
paperwork suggested they were given the
transportation of functional weapons
like these was illegal Swift action
involving law enforcement was taken
resulted in the SWAT team cracking down
on a warehouse full of guns that were
once planned for usage in World War Z
despite such a massive show made out of
securing the weapons no legal processing
would come about from this matter in
February 2012 it was revealed that
Hungarian authorities had failed to
figure out who was responsible for all
those guns unable to pin down a guilty
party charges over the matter were
dropped the whole thing generated some
headlines for a few months thanks to a
Brad Pitt movie getting embroiled in
foreign legal trouble and it's mostly
proved to be Much Ado About Nothing in
hindsight though this entire event is
just one of many instances where World
War Z kept generating the kinds of news
headlines that studio Executives have
nightmares about as if the scramble to
get the proper third act for World War Z
wasn't enough for major behind the
scenes troubles on this feature the film
was also ripe with problems with its
cinematography original cinematographer
Robert Richardson recalled to The
Hollywood Reporter in 2016 that he was
initially hired to lens the movie and
worked incredibly hard to figure out the
look of the feature originally he seemed
to be in the same creative step with
director Mark Forrester and Paramount
pitcher Executives unfortunately
Richardson would quickly discover that
all of his plans for how to shoot the
movie had been abandoned further
problems emerged once Paramount brass
decided that World War Z would be
released in digital 3D a format that
Richardson's original look for the movie
didn't account for with World War Z Now
strained comically far from Richardson's
original Vision he didn't want his name
to be on this potential Blockbuster I
took my name off
World War Z this was a significant loss
for World War Z given the esteemed
pedigree Richardson has cultivated
working with filmmakers like Quentin
Tarantino and Martin Scorsese Ben
saracen would eventually step into the
role of cinematographer on the feature
and bring this tormented aspect of World
War Z to fruition for Cinema Bland the
3D release of World War Z was not made
public knowledge until the Future Super
Bowl commercial while it was a sudden
announcement it shouldn't have been a
surprise that World War Z was shown in
digital 3D the film was released in 2013
after all when every movie studio was
still chasing extraordinary box office
returns boosted by 3D ticket prices the
abrupt nature of World War Z being
converted to digital 3D appears to be
reflected in comments from director Mark
Forrester to collider in March 2013. the
director noted that he had concerns over
how the Fast Cuts and handheld camera
work in World War Z would translate in
digital 3D while Forester wasn't
dismissive of digital 3D filmmaking his
comments about how it was implemented in
World War Z indicate that it was a
hurried decision
the World War Z novel by Max Brooks was
praised for getting into the
nitty-gritty of how a zombie apocalypse
could occur while making the eventual
Night of the Living Dead scenario feel
incredibly tangible it was the last of
us before the last of us ever existed in
terms of making a post-apocalyptic
zombie story feel so deeply human and
rooted in everyday reality by contrast
the movie was standard action-pair they
featured cartoonishly powerful zombies
and little of the substantive qualities
that got the original World War Z book
to be so popular in the first place plus
limiting the scope of the movie to just
Brad Pitt's protagonist meant that the
World War Z movie missed out on the
fascinating Global events that the World
War Z novel covered before the summer of
2013 began Box Office Mojo published its
predictions for what movies would end up
being the biggest of the summer World
War Z came in at number 12 but the
website predicting that the film
wouldn't do terribly but that it would
fare better internationally than it
would in domestic markets Box Office
Mojo would further report that even
Paramount pitchers wasn't expecting
record-breaking sums of cash from the
pig's opening weekend with the studio
projecting it were gross just under or
over 40 million dollars on opening
weekend but then World War Z managed to
surprise everyone with a hefty 66
million dollar debut a sizable haul
despite this Blockbuster opening against
Monsters University in just one week
after Man of Steel the combination of
Brad Pitt and large-scale zombie attacks
was just too good for General audiences
to miss out on in its worldwide box
office around World War Z would manage
an astonishing
531.8 million dollars including 202.7
million dollars in North America alone
even on a massive 190 million dollar
budget World War Z was clearly a
profitable exercise as early as 2012
Executives at Paramount Pictures and
Brad Pitt were both excitedly talking
about the possibility that World War Z
could go on for multiple movies with a
global zombie apocalypse there was
certainly enough material here to span
more than one Motion Picture especially
if they tapped into some of the book
material left on the table we have so
many ideas and so much information that
we we think we we got a lot of stuff to
mine from yeah or two J.A bayona was
later hired to direct this prospective
Sequel and a June 2017 release date was
announced in 2015 with a flurry of
activities surrounding the sequel World
War Z 2 was looking like a sure thing
after a few more years of development at
bayona's departure from the director's
chair David Fincher entered talks to
helm the sequel which would have
reunited the acclaimed auteur with a
spike Club leading man by 2018 five
years after the first world war Zia
debuted Fincher's sequel was beginning
to ramp up pre-production however in
February 2019 Paramount pitchers canned
World War Z II pit was reportedly
displeased over the decision which came
down to the top brass at Paramount
pitchers dragging their feet on giving
the movie a proper green light the lack
of enthusiasm from the studio execs
finally led to the sequel perishing
after years of development
foreign